the companies that they own collectively
I think do about 100 million in revenue
I think that now that private companies
are staying private for long and not
going public as much what I think needs
to happen is I think the venture
capitalists a lot of VC firms need to
start buying companies and just need to
own them for the cash flow versus
wanting something to go public or get
bought and so what I think is gonna
happen is I think a lot of these VC
firms are almost going to turn into
hedge funds or private equity funds
we're gonna they're gonna buy and
operate a lot more than they are now and
that's related to that so I don't think
VCS will do it but the sort of New Age
VCS that are gonna be hybrids so like
andreessen horowitz shifted their model
where they're not a VC there now I
forgot what it's called but like they
wanted to be able to just own
cryptocurrency theirs buy it and hold it
so they needed to reclassify and then
this guy Chamath he basically has a fund
called social capital it started off as
a traditional VC fund and then like he
had to restart it for all kinds of
reasons but one of the things he does
now is he has this thing called ass pack
which is his special purpose vehicle for
taking companies public so you're a
company you don't want to go public he's
already public and he just acquires that
you know it's taking your company I
believe is up is that how the mechanics
work so they just did this with Virgin
Galactic and so it's like a fast track
to being public and getting that
liquidity without having to go and be
you know your own independent listing
yeah I'm into that I know Andrew
Wilkinson is probably listening he owns
tiny capital and they do they've been
doing this the companies that they own
collectively I think do about 100
million in revenue and he I think takes
dividends and buys companies with the
cash flow right and it's an awesome
model but a lot of these companies like
brand lists there's no cash flow right
it's gonna be a cash sink it's one of
these go big or go to zero and in this
stuff in this case it went to zero yeah
but at the same class fee it doesn't
have to be but it's also that is also
valid right like to do that do what like
jet tried to do just like you know they
never made their core business work sold
for three billion dollars because they
they went for the plough money and today
try to get the
and then be the first to have scale
doing what we do I know it's a it's a
model
[Music]